libre et indépendant c'est le nom du
nouveau groupe formé par cinq élus de la
majorité de la droite et du centre à
plaisir lors du dernier conseil
municipal à l'origine de cette scission
un vote celui de deux adjointes et d'un
conseiller municipal délégué qui se sont
opposés à la hausse des impôts locaux
lors de l'élaboration du nouveau budget
un choix que n'a pas apprécié la mère
joséphine coleman ce berger elle a donc
décidé de proposer qu'il soit démis de
leurs fonctions
quand on a une délégation d'adjoint il
consomme et volontairement dans
l'opposition forcément je suis obligé de
prendre en tant que maire des
responsabilités qui sont des
responsabilités et bien pour enlever la
délégation je les ai gardées le conseil
municipal
j'ai gardé cette ouverture en exemple
voilà j'espérais qu'il est soit dans la
majorité avec nous ils ont préféré
monter un groupe à paris mais l'écouté
c'est pas grave c'est la politique
véronique garnon séverine fille ou
perdre leur poste d'adjointe et ne
siégeront plus dans la majorité
elles ont été rejointes par trois autres
collègues et ont décidé de former ce
nouveau groupe on se retrouve puni
exclut donc à partir de là on est obligé
de répondre par monter notre propre
groupe
est-ce que vous avez vu au conseil
départemental
lorsqu'ils ont voté le budget le budget
il n'a pas été voté à l'unanimité
depuis il y en a qu était excusé il y en
a qu à dénoncer c'est antidémocratique
maintenant chaque firme et j'affirmerai
mes positions
mes idées mais on ne réfléchit avec le
groupe que nous venons de créer au sein
de ce conseil municipal du 19 mai nous
allons continuer effectivement pour
essayer d'avoir le meilleur pour notre
vive attention attention effectivement
dit si on reprenait
l'opposition déplore la situation parle
d'une attitude peu élégante et d'un
manque de démocratie au sein du conseil
municipal concernant la cause de ces
tensions donc la hausse des impôts
la mère de plaisir affirme une nouvelle
fois ne pas avoir eu d'autre solution
face à la diminution des dotations de
l'état